y manifiestan contra lo que consideran
son leyes racistas y anti democráticas
miles de estadounidenses marcharon en
las calles de washington exigiendo que
se apruebe la llamada ley por el avance
de los derechos civiles jon louis que le
da más poder al gobierno para bloquear
cualquier legislación que sea
discriminatoria desde enero por lo menos
18 estados del país con mayoría
republicana han aprobado 30 leyes
electorales restrictivas
votar es algo muy importante no se trata
de estar de acuerdo se trata de tu
derecho y cuando tienes el derecho a
expresarte realmente estás haciendo
justicia
los participantes de la marcha
celebraron el aniversario 58 de la
histórica marcha en washington cuando el
líder de los derechos civiles martin
luther king juniors dio su famoso
discurso llamado tengo un sueño en 1963
y uso el 6 de enero vieron una
insurrección contra el derecho al voto
de la gente
hoy vieron a 20.000 personas caminar por
las calles hacia el capitolio para
representar la resurrección del derecho
al voto de martin luther king juniors
la insurrección versus la resurrección
tras las denuncias infundadas de
supuesto fraude hechas por donald trump
tras perder las elecciones en 2020
legisladores republicanos de muchos
estados procedieron a restringir el voto
por correo es el caso del estado de
texas donde la cámara baja estatal
aprobó la ley sb 1 que entre otras
prohíbe votar desde un automóvil y
amenaza con imputar delitos graves si se
envían votos por correo a quien no lo
haya solicitado los demócratas de texas
llegaron incluso a abandonar el estado
durante semanas en un intento por
impedir la votación la ley jean-louis
que ya fue aprobada por la cámara baja
necesita 60 votos en el senado para que
logre avanzar un escenario poco probable